on parle de sanctions maintenant il ya
une nouvelle salve qui a été lancée ce
mercredi par les européens les 27 cible
cette fois le secteur maritime russe et
les crypto monnaie aussi ils s'en
prennent également à trois banques
biélorusse caroline de camaret on vous
retrouve au parlement de strasbourg les
européens à l'ours 10 à l'ours disent
donc leurs sanctions contre contre
moscou
voilà il y avait déjà eu trois rente de
sanctions qui ont été complétés
aujourd'hui d'abord on a débranché trois
banques biélorusse de la fameuse
plateforme financière
donc international swift afin d'éviter
que les russes qu'on tourne justement
leur propre débranchement de swift par
par la biélorussie on a ajouté
d'ailleurs des oligarques russes à la
liste noire des sanctions vous le disais
sur le secteur maritime parce que
l'espace aérien a déjà était beaucoup
traité il a été interdit le survol par
les avions russe de l'espace aérien
européen et puis aussi l'exportation de
technologies qui pourraient aider le
secteur aéronautique russe et en
particulier leurs avions de combat
depuis en fait si on fait le calcul
l'addiction de la crimée en 2014 il ya
tout de même
880 personnes qui ont été sanctionnés
cinquante trois entités qui ne peuvent
plus entrer dans l'union européenne et
dont les avoirs sont gelés et il faut
dire que la russie allait beaucoup plus
plombé maintenant par les sanctions
qu'elle ne l'était en 2014 elle veut
d'ailleurs remboursé en roubles ses
dettes c'est ce qu'elle a annoncé plus
tôt quand en devises étrangères au pays
qu'elles jugent hostile qui comprennent
évidemment les américains tous les pays
de l'union européenne mais le rouble a
perdu les deux tiers de sa valeur c'est
une stratégie
effectivement un petit peu de
contournement mais qui ne masque pas que
cette russie a est très proche du défaut
de paiement
caroline d'autres mesures pourraient
être annoncées cette semaine de la part
des européens puisque les chefs d'état
et de gouvernement se retrouvent demain
et vendredi pour un sommet à versailles
la question de la dépendance au gaz et
au carburant rue sera posée et cela
inquiète notamment les pays d'europe de
l'est qui eux sont très dépendants du
gaz russe
voilà tout à fait si même d'ailleurs au
parlement européen aujourd'hui il ya un
grand débat avec la présidente
estonienne sur les mesures à appliquer à
l'ukraine en vérité les américains
estiment que ce qui changerait la donne
en plus des sanctions financières s'est
vu dire véritablement un embargo sur le
pétrole et sur le gaz qui l'ont annoncé
alors il pousse un petit peu dans leurs
retranchements les européens mais nous
ça nous ferait beaucoup plus mal
pourquoi et bien parce que notre
dépendance à l'or le pétrole c'est de 20
% 1 et ça c'est jouable on peut
l'importer plus facilement mais par
contre notre dépendance au gaz russe
elle est il est allé de 40%
effectivement avec des papes line qu'on
ne peut pas inventer tout d'un coup et
pour l'allemagne c'est 55% et pour
certains pays ont parlé de l'est de
l'europe la lettonie par exemple la
république tchèque c'est 100 % et même
la finlande 100 % donc évidemment vous
comprenez que le vieux continent
effectivement essaye de se défaire est
là il a déjà lancé hier un plan de
résilience pour se défaire des deux
tiers de sa dépendance au gaz russe et
notamment en stockant énormément de gaz
en vue de l'hiver 2022 vous voyez mais
aussi en essayant de diversifier de le
plus possible les approvisionnements
mais c'est difficile je le disais et
puis l'union européenne elle a fait
quand même des choses très inédite côté
armement aussi ont fait des gestes
inédit on a livré des armes aux
ukrainiens qui commencent à arriver sur
le terrain même si les polonais n'ont
pas pu livrer la trentaine d'avions qui
étaient des mig-29
finalement fabriquer un peu par les
russes et que les que les ukrainiens
savons opérer parce que là ce serait
provoquer un conflit direct mais les
armements qui commencent à arriver donc
l'union européenne est véritablement une
force qui travaille beaucoup à une
solution et elle a arrêté la guerre en
en ukraine et demain et bien il y aura
effectivement de nouvelles déclarations
politiques à un sommet extraordinaire
convoquée par le président emmanuel
macron à versailles qui va traiter
essentiellement de l'ukraine merci pour
ce point caroline de camaret à
strasbourg